hello everyone today we'll go over the
step-by-step instructions to add an
additional remote using this Pro key box
kit to begin you must have one working
key to add additional remote this kit is
compatible with 2014 to 2018 GMC Sierra
1500 I will list compatibility guide at
the end of this video this kit comes
with the aftermarket remote the
programmer tool and the instruction
manual if you have your own unprogrammed
remote you can also purchase the
programmer tool separately as an
alternative option this tool will work
on any aftermarket remote or the
original remote today we'll program the
aftermarket remote with the kit first
then we will use the kit to reprogram
our own original remote once you use
this programmer tool it will lock to
your Carin this means you can reuse it
as many times as you want in your
vehicle but not in any other vehicle so
to begin the process you need to connect
the tool to the OBD board the programmer
will tell you you can program up to four
remotes press enter all remotes will be
erased and require reprogramming in Next
Step press enter insert the key into the
ignition and turn it to the on position
do not start the car
then press
enter from there the programmer will
communicate to your
vehicle we will reprogram original
remote first by pressing and holding
lock and unlock buttons for 15 seconds
or until you hear the beeping tone
here we will repeat the same step by
holding the lock and unlock buttons for
each remote we want to
add when you're done with adding remotes
press enter you'll have to wait a few
seconds before you hear this
tone this means it is all done so next
unplug the tool and let's test the
remotes
here we can see it's working and it's
all good to go hope you enjoyed the
video thank you for watching